you don't even watch the videos on
Sidetrack what the hell is wrong with
you anyway hi
guys chel I just caught me telling
Matthew off there just a little bit um
how are
everybody
hello feelings are a little bit hurt
though you just told me off well start
watching the videos I mean what suppos
do your bloody homework if you don't
watch it how do I expect anyone else to
watch
it
guys um I wanted to have a little bit of
a chat today and we're going to avoid
the word woke as much as we possibly can
all right because this isn't about that
but it is about social media and hate
clicks and people being very negative
about stuff before it even gets made all
right which is a
problem and the reason why I wanted to
talk about it was because I had a chat
yesterday with somebody that um was is
Wednesday um that somebody that works in
like um compiling metadata and stuff and
he was actually telling me there's been
conversations at Warner Brothers at the
moment about the new Babylon 5 reboot
something I'm quite excited about I'd
love to see what JMS is planning to do
with the Babylon 5
remake um because I actually got the
original Creator back so long story
short Warner Brothers thought because
they got JMS to remake it that nobody
would get angry but people have still
got angry why do you need to remake
Babylon 5 it's going to be a woke mess
it's going to be blah blah blah so
basically I've going to ask a question
because Warner Brothers are now
considering canceling the project
because of these this
negativity is negativity and these hate
clicks and trolling and all this stuff
that we have to put up with but we tend
to ignore actually starting to have real
world effect and we're actually going to
I mean
they look at metadata and we'll talk
about metadata in a minute but they look
at metadata when they're thinking about
things like Stargate and stuff first of
all just I just throw that out there
first what what what do you think what
do we think about the negativity what do
we think
about actually impacting Executives
thinking first
thoughts I'll start off I was thinking
about this on Wednesday I read some
comment it was
um I can't remember the show it was it
was about it wasn't about U anything we
typically talk about but it's like the
fans are going to start getting what
they deserve that was my thought because
we see all you know we we see all these
um shows that we absolutely love the
fans are really engaged right and then
you know the series ends or something
and whenever there's a
reboot it's not I don't think it's the
fans that are saying anything I think
it's just the hate trolls that come in
just needing clicks and needing ad
revenue and but
the
fans because it's difficult for fans to
speak up and just keep it loud as much
as the
trolls I think that we're going to see
less and less good Sci-Fi less and less
good fantasy because
the trolls are going to start
controlling uh what we see and that's
really going to be pathetic but
it's I you know I think it's we're going
to get the Sci-Fi Wii uh deserve not the
Sci-Fi we
want I mean Matt if you're an executive
over in you know
Disneyland and you know you're thinking
about spending a hundred million doar on
a new TV series so you leak it out there
through channels like sidet trk and you
get you just see loads and loads of
comments like I don't want this this is
a load of rubbish blah blah blah would
it make you think
twice it would
but see my thinking with it
all is there's always negativity with
everything it's
[Music]
always when there's negativity about a
show or someone's race or someone's
gender or whatever these people want to
have a bloody [__] fit about it's
always a vocal minority not the majority
yeah most people who watch it will not
believe those kind of things but because
they see it in the comments might then
start thinking those kind of things and
it's kind of like a vicious
circle um what stormmy was saying about
um people basically perpetuating it
YouTubers I'm gonna take us out of it
because I'd hope our audiences don't
take everything we say at face value and
like everything we say is just our
opinions and you you don't have to
believe everything we say but there are
people who watch YouTube YouTubers and
just take their opinion as fact and
realistically those people are just gen
regular people who probably don't know
[__] about
[__] and that's what causes a lot of
negativity but I I don't know if if if I
was an executive and I was seeing it
then yeah I'd be a little bit worried
but it's I think they need to to
basically realize that it's not what the
majority of people want it's just trolls
on the internet people it's happened for
years with Doctor Who U Back in the 2005
reboot when Christoph recson left and
they announced David Tenant people were
saying he's too young he's not going to
make a good doctor he's far too young
um yeah loads Lo loads of loads of mat
Smith people said he looked weird and
stuff Matt Smith who's this guy he looks
weird David Tenon is now the doctor for
everyone he is the he is the face of
Doctor Who mean he's coming back for the
60th anniversary because of that very
fact people just I don't know I hate the
fact that people see something and make
a judgment on it before they've actually
seen it I've always hated that even when
the whole rings of power thing when
people were making judgments on that
before that came
out it was just like you've not seen it
yet why are you making a judgment of it
you've seen a trailer perhaps but you've
not seen the
thing that
was it was always yeah but it's always
YouTubers and like articles and stuff
perpetuating all of this oh it's going
to be this it's going to be that without
actually knowing what it's going to be
it's just their opinions but because
people take it as fact and that face
value it becomes fact in people's minds
and that's that's
dangerous
yeah what do you think Harris sh like
Devil's Advocate a bit oh my to run off
of what Matt was just saying at the end
there and what Tom 89 said social media
has too much impact on things nowadays
is that bad thing Barbie and offenheim
are literally are are
flourishing not just just as two movies
but the film industry as a whole right
now because of social media I mean even
with things that we don't particularly
love like the sco Scooby-Doo uh show
that Velma show nobody liked it but
everybody hate clicked it everybody
watched it and they renewed it for a
season two not because people loved it
but because everyone went there to click
it whether they liked it or not they
watched a good chunk of it and it made
the studio a bunch of money it was one
of the only things that made them a
bunch of money while these strikes were
going on initially of course kind of
kept pushing on
but we live in a day where a dislike a
hate comment equals just as much if not
more than an actual like or an actual
comment like pushing something forward
I'm not saying that's good or bad but
it's something that's been prominent in
the industry since since there's been an
industry when when Batman was cast with
Michael Keaton in 89 I wasn't born yet
y'all might remember a little better
some of some of us Matt and I probably
don't remember necessarily super duper
well but I was I was do yall remember
Michael Keaton's casting reaction what
about Hayden Christenson in Star Wars as
a kid people bullied and belittled him
like nobody's business and now half a
generation later he's loved and adored
and beloved by an entire fan base
sometimes time is the best part of all
of it and if we get so caught up
honestly and it's better to live in the
moment than it is to live in the past or
the future but if you get caught up only
in the hate in the moment there's a lot
more to look at and it's a 247 new cycle
that stuff goes away just as quick as it
comes up we're human beings we talk like
that anyway I feel like it's it's gon to
be there one way or another and it's
it's the power that we give it or the
power that we don't give it yeah and
lately we've been given a lot of power I
totally agree with you the My worry is
executives are going to start making
decisions based on what the trolls are
going to do like VMA season two yeah
yeah and you know and I mean I did I saw
the uh the ads for Barbie when it first
came out I was like wondering the hell
is this all about no it was not it was
not on my watch list at all whatsoever
so then I went to go watch it and I
laughed the whole way through it one of
the better movies of I mean it was just
awesome you know and it was like it
reminds me of the Matrix marketing when
it first came out I was looking at it
like what it's just the the I saw the
ads on TV and people flipping around and
dodging bullets I really I just I have
no and then I went to go I said holy
[__] why didn't they advertise this you
know was true you know and so I had a
preconception based on their own
marketing and preconception man it's
just hard to shake it really is uh but
yeah it's
um you know I I just you know I just
hope Executives can you know stay true
to their Vision you know and and say
well you know am I going to let some
punk from Kansas City you know you know
bring down my entire you know fan Empire
based on you know what he you know
tweeted out at 3:00 a.m. while puking
his guts out on Warcraft or something
you know
it's but I don't know how you comat it
except unless they start using these
trolls in their advertising campaign
like somebody that like run a Barbie um
run a Barbie ad highlighting the trolls
giving it one stars or you know using
very vulgar language towards uh Mar G
Robie or something and then you know
everyone loves the movie then you start
belittling the trolls remember no one a
bully will back down I mean bully will
just collaps bullies cannot in any
circumstance face before Barbie made a
billion dollars there were certain
YouTube channels that I watch and or
used to watch anyway because I've
stopped because I caught them in a fib
but anyway we'll ignore that um who said
it was the most dangerous movie that's
ever been made yeah even I'm watching it
by the end of it thinking I should
probably apologize to my mom for
something but I mean um you know it was
there was some serious like agenda and
like politics and stuff in that movie
and I imagine a lot of little girls came
out going Mommy why do you hate Daddy
and like I don't I don't I love daddy
very
much but it was a great movie and and
and I think I don't think it's as
dangerous in that I think sometimes
having an alternative Viewpoint in a
movie isn't that sometimes the point we
love sci-fi how many times we watch
Sci-Fi and go I don't agree with with
what they're arguing there but it's made
me think about it and isn't that when
the best you know T TV is I agree I was
just gonna say that I was just gonna say
that if you if you come out that movie
thinking it's done its job people saying
that it's it's dangerous dangerous to
who dangerous to the people who are
against that mindset me because my wife
now thinks she can tell me what to do
and I'm just
like we tell you what
to and Jay has been
cancelled chill brought up a good point
though like with the trolls and stuff
and She-Hulk She-Hulk brought up trolls
a couple different times and at first it
worked really well and then it back
fired on them by the end because they
double down they they they beaten the
bullies down to a degree and then double
down and got themselves beat up again
after the fact so it it is a weird
little like where what line is it where
do you cross where do you jump I don't
know it's it's it's a weird little gauge
I guess that was the thing with She-Hulk
it was I actually I laughed the first
time they did oh yeah and by the way I
wouldn't hit my wife she would beat the
crap out of me and I am a little bit
nervous I said that too loudly and she's
downstairs she might have heard me so
um
um um but that was the problem shehulk
they they they did they did poke fun
they did poke the
bear and but then they kept poking the
bear and I'm like at some point that
Bear's going to turn around it's going
to eat you and and but the problem is I
think they they they actually Justus
they ended up justifying the people that
were saying this was a a bunch of
rubbish you know if they' have sort of
like made that little poke and then you
know it makes the bullies look stupid
like he said but then by by doing it I I
felt by the end of it I'm like going I
think I'm with the woke people now this
is this is just crap and and that's the
problem when you've got something like
that when you've they went into that
with an agenda and the agenda was
they're gonna shout at us so let's shout
back and the Ghostbusters with boobs
made the same mistake they did exactly
the same thing they they they read all
the reports about they said ghost B
can't be a bunch of women we'll show
them so we'll just make a load of
feminist jokes all the way through and
it's ruin the
film and if they' approached that with
it
was W with you know just being blind to
the gender you know be just just not
even mentioning it you know unless you
know you can throw in the The Casual
comment like you know I had a bad date
or something in terms of just you know
getting the exposition moving forward no
one would have noticed and it probably
been a really bloody good movie yeah
yeah one or two little jokes here and
there would have been absolutely fine
they brilliant actors and actresses in
it but they just went way too far and
shehulk went way too far as well but I
would still argue and this is okay well
this has going to the next thing then is
it just bad writing that we're actually
talking about with a lot of this stuff I
have tried really hard to watch Star
Trek Discovery um because I was talking
to a guy from the shuttle pod show Mark
over there and he said no go on give it
a try give it a try go on it's really
and I'm watching it and I'm like going I
don't care about the people that shout
woke at this or whatever this is just
boring it's not very good um I I I don't
really understand the people that are
shouting woke at it because somebody's
transgender or somebody else's asexual
what I don't care and I can't notice
because my brain is just going turn it
off turn it off turn it off turn this is
D I hate this show and it's just it's
just
bad um are we talking about bad
writing I think so I think it would be
bad writing because there are plenty of
sci-fi shows or just regular shows
out there that do these storylines
really really well something I watched
recently sex education the fourth is the
fourth season or the third season I
don't know they talk there's a lot about
transgenders in there a lot about
asexuality um and
disability but it fits in with the story
it's not like they've just shoehorned it
in for the sake of spreading a message I
think the whole show is a message or
it's the show is sex education it's
educating anyone who's watching it about
these different minorities different
sexualities different abled people Etc I
think they do it really well because the
story is good and it fits in quite well
with sci-fi um what what's the name of
the show The Orville did a really good
transgender
story but that wasn't they actually flip
both sides of the thingy though they
actually made both part sides of the
argument I thought it was really clever
it was really good it wasn't a obviously
there was a there was a message there I
don't think it was necessarily an agenda
it was just a message of education for
both sides but it wasn't out of place
for that for that show that show it was
something that they've been building up
to since season one when they found out
TOA was actually born a female Etc
but I don't know yeah I I
just bad writing and and trying to to
deliver a message is a bad idea if if
you do good writing you can deliver a
message
anyway yeah so it has to be good it has
to be good Sci-Fi going back to the
beginnings of sci-fi there was always a
message behind it there wasn't there you
could read George Orwell or any of thing
and there's
always something behind it isn't there
oh there is a message all right in
anything George Orwell
where the hell you
been George Orwell would have a stroke
if he came back to
like but that's my point isn't it a lot
of these original writers they knew they
couldn't actually say what they wanted
to say they said it in a metaphor of
sci-fi you they couldn't talk about how
slavery is probably not very good so
I'll create a story about a robot that
is in you know like this sort of thing
and isn't that
I'm watching I'm watching next
generation at the moment there's plenty
of story lines in that which if they
made it today people would shout woke
it's not woke it's just it's just I hate
the word woke I've always hated it
because the original meaning of the word
is just being awake to Injustice and
it's just to be aware of your
surroundings and being aware of other
people and their struggles or how how
they live their lives thank you people
have now bastardized that um word into
now this is negative we don't want to
see transgenders we don't want to see
gay people we don't want to see black
people we don't want to see anyone who
isn't a white straight
male
whatever um I don't know why I'm going
with that I've literally just lost my
trail thought because I've got angry I'm
sorry I do think you've got a point that
I'm gonna play devil a little bit though
I do I I hate the word woke you know
what I do I we've lost many subscribers
because I've done videos when I explain
exactly what you've just said and I said
I hate this word and Fox News sort of
took it and they even say on the BBC now
and it's a word we're stuck with and I
hate
it the problem is there are a bunch of
people that that get angry about how TV
has gone woke and I've said this loads
of times but and they've got a point
there's a lot of people that have really
thought about how like I say sometimes
the agenda overtakes the story and
they've got a point the problem is
there's also a bunch of people in the
same thing that are actually just bigots
that actually are just racist sexist
they never want to see anybody in trans
they don't want to see any of these
things on the TV screen and they've now
got a little gang they can join up with
and Shout woke everything and one of the
byproducts of that is when
somebody whether they've got a point or
not comes out and says things like
Barbie is one of the most dangerous
movies that's ever been made it gets a
million views and a load of
clicks because it feeds into actually a
lot of people's
worries and concerns
and I think it feeds into that like
emotional part of your brain that's not
really that bright PE people have these
pre preconceptions of what the movie is
based on their own World Views or based
on something someone's already told them
and then someone makes an article about
this is the most dangerous thing in the
world and then it's validation for them
so they'll click it and they'll share it
and then it spreads that message even
more the concerning the whole you know
woke issue in uh creative content
um I guess this about a month or so ago
maybe a little bit more uh there was a
musician named Tyler chers if you guys
ever heard of him of course okay chers
yeah so he came out with this uh song in
your love and the video has these two
coal miners right two dudes you know
they have a relationship but one dies a
black lung right and I made a comment on
that video actually it's the number one
comment still oh was two months ago
and I was talking about you know growing
up in West Virginia and all of my family
members that worked in Colmes died a
black lung every single one of them
Jesus you know and the people said well
this is woke I don't I'm tired of seeing
this all the time and I'm just wondering
I was trying to recall back when what
was the
other was there any really other popular
country music video that had two gay
characters I mean at all no whenever he
released it he got a lot of flak for it
but he got a lot of people supporting
him too which was nice yeah and and you
know it was so even though we have in
the entire genre that I could find
one one gay couple and the story is
really about Black Lung and losing a
partner to black lung losing a family
member to black lung and how you do not
want to see anybody die a black lung
that is a painful [__] thing to
watch but
the haters overlooked that whole issue
and they focused on the one thing we
don't want to see any more queers we
don't want to see any more this any that
and what's the other video what's the
other country music video These and I'm
and I'm using this example as like a lot
of times these things don't haven't
popped up or they or it's been a part of
like sci-fi you know for George Orwell
you know always wrote about these things
I mean the the these themes have been
around for a very long time now we're
just you know a 100 years later 50 we're
all upset about
it can go to popcorn Po's comment here
um starbook was gender swapped people
still love B Sky Galactic because it was
a great story minus the ended yes it did
fear can we just point out though that
let's not rewrite history particularly
there was a lot of hate aimed oh the
whole starbook thing to the point they
had to pay Dirk Benedict to go and meet
Kate sackoff in a
Starbucks um there's a photo of them
both having a cigar holding cigars and
and and him basically they had to pay B
Benedict to actually meet her and then
him he basically gave her his his um
blessing sort of thing um there was a
lot of hate aimed at that a lot of
hate show was so good it won people over
I mean and you know the character that
she played the character that he played
you know they they played the same
character they were you know they were
still kind of you know rambunctious they
were kind of really am I going to follow
orders today I'm not sure if I will
let's see I've got these gambling debts
I've got a horrific smoking habit I mean
you know it's but they were totally but
they portrayed the character totally
they had their own themes on it you know
and um yeah Katie sackoff man I felt so
far sorry for her no one had seen the
the the the first the first frame of the
of of the new Battlestar Galactica and
just I mean it was horrible I mean it
was it was shameful what these fans did
to her and I am appreciative of the fact
that she stuck with it and proved them
wrong and gave us a really really
good uh story and and the writers and
the other actors it was just God that
was marvelous you know and imagine you
know if uh Studio Executives today were
worried about clicks or negative
clicks what we would have lost you know
we would have lost you know a sack off's
um translation of that character we
would have lost
that uh we'd have lost so much in terms
of Art and entertainment just because of
haters and I think that's the dangerous
thing here is we let them take control
of our own entertainment and those guys
are not entertaining but I'm so glad
that sack off um stuck with it because
we got a lot out of it in it was awesome
it was I mean it helped that she is just
amazing yes which is I mean if she
hadn't if she'd have done a bad
performance or she'd been written badly
then it wouldn't have worked but and
I've always said that um I if you're
gonna gender swap a character you better
do it for a good reason right I don't
necessarily want to see Shirley Holmes a
new
1880s you know set murder mystery thing
instead of
Sherlock but with starbook the writers
did it very much with the attitude of
this is a boring character we need to do
something this character has been been
done to death we need to do something
with it let's make him a woman gez okay
you know and they did it they did it
with very much of purpose in mind and
that's been done before I do worry
though that other Executives have got in
the mind went that worked let's gender
swap somebody else because we'll get a
load of negative um clicks and things
but there's no such thing as bad
publicity if they're talking about show
who gives a [__] I think that's part of
the problem it's not
necessarily
can can we gender swap can we do these
risque let's say story lines it's shall
we because it's going to generate this m
this this these amount of clicks and
this this level of hatred that is just
going to put us to the top of the pile
and I think that's dangerous in itself
because doing it for the the sake of
generating
traffic is a disingenuous way of telling
that story you're not doing it because
you want to tell that story or highlight
those people you're doing it because you
know you're going to get negative
attention and that's extremely dangerous
because there are genuine people out
there that want to tell a good story who
have had genuine experiences anything
Russell T Davis has done um about um
like homosexuality in the
80s he's done a lot of stuff about that
because
he's he's homosexual he grew up in the
80s he's got a story to tell they're all
fantastic but he's never been one to
like push a um push push it for clicks
kind of thing it's just if he he he's
he's part of that Community he wants to
tell a story but these Executives that
think oh I want to generate a lot of a
lot of traffic here let's do it because
we know it's going to do
do this that's damaging incredibly
damaging so so so here's the question if
someone was to remake
alien and recast Ripley as a man do they
deserve to be shot or just
hung feter an alien fet an alien all
right you know and it's like you
know I don't remember you know in the
late 70s when uh alien first came out
you know how hard you there was no there
was no backlash no one called it a
feminist movie or anything you know when
uh I disagree they they
did there was quite like quite a lot of
negativity aimed at um alien when it
first came out uh aliens in particular
um because they there were people that
said well they've made these she's made
these soldiers look silly but I think
that was before social media and stuff
but I actually was asked about this a
while ago and I actually did find some
newspaper articles at the time saying
that but that's again one of those
things it was forgotten because she was
so brilliant well you know and the uh
there were several as I recall the
biggest issue about alien when it came
out in theaters was um it was
such it was um such a shocking movie I
mean it was it was banned in the town I
lived in I mean it was literally banned
because it not for any feminist reasons
but because it was the scene you know of
the uh metamorph coming out of the guy's
chest was yeah I mean that they actually
banned it uh I had to get bum a ride
over to another the next town over to
see it and it was in newspapers how you
know a lot of theaters were Banning
because it's so graphic you know and I
don't I you know I don't recall
I really don't recall you know
newspapers or anybody and this is when
we only had newspapers in three TV
channels of um of just uh people
being you know um concerned about uh
Ripley being a woman I don't think they
did with alien it was aliens there was a
Oh aliens
was yeah aliens there yeah that's a
whole different set of yeah yeah there
was um they felt that it had an
anti-military message I remember that um
yeah there was a lot of critics that
just came out and boom it was another
amazing movie it's
probably it was just amazing I well you
know of course the director
shabby yeah
exactly address this question was
Russell the one who agenda swap Doctor
Who no that was Chris
chibar um who bought it in with the
master being swapped to Missy which was
a fantastic performance I love Russell
did um posed the question to the BBC
about having the next Doctor be a female
but it was shut down and then it was
Chris tribal that managed to get it uh
get it to happen and then it was no it
wasn't Chris sorry it was Steven muffett
Steven muffet's run but then Chris CH
obviously took over um for 13's
run what you have to remember with the
doctor is they're all different
characters so they're not gender
swapping it's just a different character
and it's an alien do we know that sex
works in the same or gender works in the
same way for a Time Lord as it does for
a human being so yeah people need that's
what Steven Moffett did with with Missy
basically just blew out the water with
with um Missy and even before then
actually there was a storyline uh I
think it was Peter capi's Ron so again
Chris J I think uh sorry Stephen Mett um
one of the time Lords the general I
think gets killed shot and then goes
from a man into a woman and then
basically just makes a joke of I hate
you being a man I wanted to be a woman
I've always been a woman I was a man in
my last regeneration so we know
canonically that time Lords can just
like they're fluid basically there you
go and what's wrong with that they a
Time Lord Cal down unless you want to be
a ginger yeah no no no no no don't still
not a ginger but let's not bring in
gingers into this because um they all
need to be
exterminated I really hope when shoy
like you see David ten regenerating to
shoo at I really hope he goes damn I'm
still not Ginger I really wanted to say
ginger yeah I know what you mean my my
biggest issue though is really there's a
I have no problem with anybody honestly
expressing an opinion I am not going to
put my hand on my heart and say that I'm
never going to come on this channel and
go I freaking hated that show I say I
hate Discovery I don't like it I'm a
treky I don't like it um and I and I
don't have any issue with coming on here
and telling people I don't like it
because it's my opinion and I'm allowed
my opinion I do have a problem with
YouTubers that Express an opinion that
is basically just for clicks and I know
there are YouTubers out there that do
this they go with what is popular what
they think is popular and we'll get them
think and we'll get them views and they
will go this is
awful
the problem is though I've done this
video about Babylon
5 just kind of get this
reimagining and there are Executives at
the moment it's been a bit of a roller
coaster babon 5 will they won't they
will they won't they um and now the
conversations at the moment that are
happening at Warner Brothers is should
we do this because the fans clearly
don't want it because that's what the
metad dator is telling
them it hasn't even been officially
announced well not really it was kind of
officially announced but
JMS has only written the original the
pilot and there are already people out
there saying that they don't want it why
and and YouTubers jump on that bandwagon
and say yeah this is going to be this
this is gonna be that why well you know
maybe it's I'm sorry Matt go ahead no no
go ahead I was just gonna say maybe
Jamie needs to start another Twitter
campaign you know another hashtag
campaign you know JMS get off your ass
hashtag or something like that you know
oh he's ready to go don't go wrong he's
more than but I mean you know one thing
I think that you know Jamie's earlier
hashtag campaign really got the ball
rolling and really you know all of a
sudden Executives see something positive
as opposed to negative negative negative
negative on Twitter all the time or X or
whatever and maybe just we need to do it
again
Jamie what I don't know which
one gonna
say do some to
what the problem with looking at the
metadata is this is true not just for
social media but for just humans in
general people will vocalize something
if they're
dissatisfied they generally don't
vocalize it if they're satisfied now
I've worked in um sales for a really
long time yes you're one of them
everyone's judging aren't I sorry just
arguing that that's the
problem just think I think he's just
saying I don't think you meant to say
Jay's biggest problem I think you meant
to say Jay the biggest problem the
biggest problem is prejudging which
makes more sense
okay like wait no I'm sure just
literally said the opposite go on sorry
no so just just humans in general we'll
always vocalize something if we're
dissatisfied with it we generally
generally don't do it if we're satisfied
so when I worked in sales we used to
have these um NPS scores net promoter
scores which is basically a how would
you rate your service and that was
basically determining how much money we
got paid I always hated them because of
this fact people will only ever respond
to something or
Express Express their opinion if if it
was really really good like
exceptionally good or if it was bad they
won't do it if it's if they're neutral
unless something is absolutely fantastic
they won't say and if something is
absolutely or even if it's just slightly
negative they'll they'll they'll they'll
write something about it but if they're
neutral if if it if everything's as it
should be no one will say anything and I
think that's where most people sit
they'll just sit neutrally and it's the
people that see negatives that start
posting and that's what we keep seeing
it's just those
people and it's
it's it's stupid people just need to
big up their the things that they love
just just start tweeting about things
that you love well
okay I'll try to put a cap on everything
if I can with that people are gonna be
people I don't think we should try to
say one way or another whether they
should be one way or another or not you
know like like we said at the beginning
of the stream we're on here to talk
about our opinions everybody has the
right to talk about their opinions
whether they're good bad or ugly or just
darn right stupid they they have the
right to talk about them now if it comes
back to the writing and all that W with
with the concepts at hand that people
are getting frustrated about it a lot of
the times it is the writing right now
how it's it's not a a concept that is
being baked into a product as an
ingredient it's literally like this is
this is your frosting here you go like
this is all you see kind of deal this is
what we're addressing it up as it's
going to be talking about this topic
this topic this topic instead of
introducing these characters and the
story they on like uh popcorn's been
saying a whole bunch about it in the
comments he's he's saying story story
story story and it always should be
Story and there's there's always been a
case for this since film history prior
to film history and books before that
there always will be this
but if stories focus on instead of the
concept and that concept where like
sci-fi does it really well is if you
want to put it in the story it needs to
be an ingredient in the recipe it
doesn't need to be that frosting I guess
is the metaphor I can keep going back to
it needs to be something that is
inherently part of what's going on and
doesn't take away from anything else and
if you just Ram it in people's faces
just shove it in people's faces they
going to get that vital back and and
that's what people are going to focus on
online so if we go back to actually
focusing on story in the writing room
and all that and the writer's room with
the writer strike that's a whole
different conversation right now it does
correlate very much
but if we choose to focus on something
instead of the story at hand that's what
that that's the what the focus will be
on after the fact as well whether it be
after a trailer after actual episode
after a season after a movie whatever it
may
be that that that's what is still
prominent in people's mind instead of
okay well this happened at the end ofo
of the story well in the second act this
happened to kind of lead them there well
well how did that work you know instead
of going back and thinking about the
story and in the film or the TV show
that you just watched people are like oh
great well we just got this lesson and
She-Hulk thanks we just got Lon and
whatever thanks no one wants that I
guess and and whether you're agreeing or
not agreeing with the given lesson in in
a particular
medium that's not what they're there for
you're there for a good story you're
there for good characters you're there
to partially escape the real life and
the real BS and you can include the real
life and real BS inside of these things
but you have to do it meticulously and
that meticulousness has been completely
lost and just now now it's really
we have these topics that are polarizing
and very politically active right now so
let's just toss these into our our
mediums and it's frustrating it really
is for for every side of every angle
because we're not focusing on the story
we just I'll keep coming back to it
story story story story story it's the
most important part we can we can go
every single angle but it always comes
back to story always comes back to story
and we just we're missing that and and
and we need more of that nowadays
whether that's smaller writing rooms
with more pertinent ideas whether it's
larger writing rooms that work well
together either way can
work there has
been there's been a quality issue with
streaming last few years but stormmy me
and you are the the older Statesman in
this
room has there always been great
television or have we had to deal with
some absolute tripe over the years oh
suck ass tripe I mean
I I did I you know and I may be you know
um stepping on people's toes but I you
know Buck Rogers and that that did not
go over well in the 80s man it is it was
like it hurt to watch that I mean I
mean that little stupid round robot
headed thing you just wanted to kick it
you wanted to kick it it was a front to
R2D2 it was like some sort of robotic
afterbirth man you just didn't want to
look at it o
oh there was some I think the point I'm
trying to make is when there's bad
television we tend to forget it because
it's
bad I was watching a whoopy Goldberg
movie not long ago and I can't tell what
it was about but it was about an
advertising campaign or something and
she couldn't get a job because she was a
woman people wanted to hire a man so she
ended up dressing up as a as a white guy
at the end and like you know with
prosthetics and everything and all the
way through and this this film was like
the late 90s it would have been whoopy
Goldberg at the top of a chis or thing
and I'm like I've never I don't remember
this film I've never seen this before in
my life I just caught it because it just
happened to be on channel five at like 3
o'clock in the morning something it was
Bloody awful and the reason why I've
never heard about it before is because
it was Bloody awful it was there was an
agenda to the film and actually weirdly
it wasn't about race it was about gender
um you know it's like she's a woman and
couldn't get a job not a black woman
even they they didn't even mention it
even though they did make it a white guy
at the end which was you know whatever
but it wasn't but it wasn't funny it
wasn't well made and it was a bunch of
crap it was a bad
film the stuff that we're talking about
now I honestly don't think Star Trek
Discovery Discovery in 20 years time
will be considered a very good Star Trek
show it won't be watched strange new
worlds will be because it's
better
um there's always been bad television
that's my point there's always been
propaganda television there all this
stuff's always existed we'll forget
about it it won't get rewatched it will
still be on Netflix because that's how
that's what Netflix's business model is
um just put as much crap on nobody wants
to pay for and somebody will watch it
but
um I don't I honestly don't think
anything is any different today than it
was in the 90s or the 80s or the 70s
this stuff was still there it's just
that we forgot about
it
maybe let me stor me with that yeah I
mean there there was you know a lot of
crap you know from 70s 80s
and what's going on so yeah there was a
lot of crap in the 70s and 80s and it
was we never saw it again for good
reason you know
um and uh it was but there was some
really good stuff
back then that tried to that you know
was remade and it was blood awful oh God
alight let me tell you here's one
example Land That Time Forgot not not
land Time Forgot
um uh Land of the Lost Land of the Lost
I watch Land of the Lost you know the
the there was the original Saturday
morning TV show they really had really
decent writing you know from a S really
decent
writing and then will frell got a hold
of
it that film was awful and one in that
cat I love that
movie God I saw it when I was like 12
and I'll never forget it Chaka is my
favorite character ever eighty old boy
yeah it was an 8-y old boys it was
perfect for being 12 nowadays maybe not
so much but now a nice joint brings me
back to 12 real quick I did like land of
lost I loved Land of the Lost I loved um
what was the Voyage to the Bottom of the
Sea 10,000 Leagues Under the Sea I
really like that's one of them Land of
the
Giants of the Giants there there was a
voyage of wild of the SE had the Little
Submarine had another little sub
submarine that would um little yellow
thing you would like fly around I love
that it's like be movie television it
was great yeah um 19 space 1999 was
awesome I would argue that Doctor Who
was a be movie television for years it
basically was when when I was watching
it as a kid it obviously the BBC put a
lot more effort behind it then but when
I was a kid it was sort of like papy
mashe bad guys
and like CW like way yeah yeah but um
but
anyway
so I don't think we're ever going to get
away from this no I say I don't think
there's really been a lot of difference
I I don't think this is any real
different I think authors will always
write about stuff they care about and if
a writer wants to write about RAC he
will I wish and and I actually think
there's just as good really good TV as
there ever has
been um there's an argument to say a lot
more of it's on streaming and it's not
so good but people argued about they're
destroying Star Wars and then I just
watched the show and loved it on the
whole bits I didn't um but I've just
been watching
um I've I've only discovered this show
recently um things they do in the
shadows what we do in the shadows yeah
yeah you started watching it I've I've
made I've watched all four Series in
three days oh my God yes have you seen
the movie you've seen the original movie
right I'm going to I haven't watched it
yet no um I just the background while I
was working the and if anybody says oh
everything's woke nowadays I'm like go
watch
that it is glorious all the way through
and because it's a bunch of British
actors as well it's actors I know so the
one guy in it is just phenomenal Matt
Barry is my spirit
animal I've loved that guy for years
when he was on some called The IT Crowd
over here in the UK and he's he's
just um so he's
phenomenal the three top comedies in the
world right now not animated I guess are
what we do in the shadows only murders
in the building and It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia none of those
fitur your woke definitions which is
which is great you know it's like it's
they're all funny as hell in their own
way
I love all read yeah I just I just yeah
it's just great um it shouldn't be as
funny as it is and I shouldn't be
laughing as much as I the new season was
perfect it's just I mean just swearing
but for some it's because you know
they'll just go ah [__] off and and I'm
just like because of the the situation
it's hilarious it's just so funny and um
there was something about um they got
caught in a vets and and sorry like the
the thing with cats and the guy all he
does he's run past he goes get your
clothes out of me you bastards as he
runs past and I'm and it's like on his
own not funny but because it's a vampire
and the voice he uses
in hilarious tell me Mark Hamill coming
into the show wasn't
abely with his Joker voice TUC
Arizon got some big shot stars on that
show TI is best Ty ex it's mostly TAA I
guess did more of the movie and he's
definitely a producer but it's mostly
Jermaine Clement his kind of like old
writing partner and producing partner
the guy that was the villain in mini
Black 3 that shot spike out of his hands
so I had to Google that guy I know him
and because again he's British guy that
I've seen in loads of things over the
years but I didn't New Zealand he's a
New Zealand or is he oh well he's been
in a lot of British stuff I was just
assumed he was
British me stand up and stuff
over years and years ago I mean stuff I
think he's more have you ever seen
Flight of the concore
that was what he got him his that's what
I know him
from okay so that's something I never
did resonate with and I forgot all about
I love fly to the
Concord I'm kind of envious because you
a lot a lot of people I know love that
show and I never could find
the the vibe I just couldn't grasp it
smoke a joint and just press oh that's
the problem well it's a magical thing
sometimes I can't do that because
Richard Branson owns all my urine so
it's just
I I I can't I'll have to live
vicariously through you could smoke with
Richard Branson that I've watched that
man smoke many a joint on many of
different
things never mind I don't want to get
into Richard Branson's urine on on live
stream really yeah that'll end up being
a new
T-shirt oh there goes my job yeah we
so anyway guys
um we've got the last five minutes of
the stream I don't want to talk any more
about five stuff I just I just wanted to
talk about this stuff because it wound
me up um but for did you guys see the um
little interview we did last week yeah
yes
con that was kind of
awesome Matt have you stopped giggling
about it
yet no I keep telling people every every
everyone I see it like did like cuz I go
around like the schools because of my
job on Tuesday I went in spoke to the
Head teacher and I was like do you like
Stargate he was like I've heard of it I
spoke topr
right I'm so happy for you guys I was I
was just cheering you on that was the
best thing ever I'm just so happy for
you guys and yeah would stop renting and
I really loved it that you were the
first uh the first ones
in
we made I made Brad light laugh like two
three times yeah you murdered it for
everybody else it was used yeah everyone
else hates you I guess and what I mean
we may be biased just a bit but y'all
were definitely the ones that brought
the momentum and the fun to yeah which
was great everybody else had great
questions as well but y'all had good
questions and were fun while you're were
doing it
which said that my miss my M watched the
entire thing she never normally watches
anything I do but she watched that
because she knew how excited I was
and she was like you and Jay were the
best on there like yeah and I was like I
mean okay I I don't necessarily agree
but because the same crazy joy we can't
say anything but we were the best I mean
same crazy joyfulness that all four of
us have together you know through these
little Sunday chats you guys translated
that over to brat Wright and you made
him G oh holy completely great it was
awesome yeah it was awesome like I I'll
be honest I started cooking I I was like
eating a little bit while I was watching
y'all's bit then I was like okay some
other stuff to cook so I was cooking
well there's always a little bit of that
before
is reference in here we should be paying
attention to no I know I'm just
saying zoned out for like 30 40 minutes
and then I hear Jay and Matt's Voice
come back and I turn around and it was
just it was giggly and fun for another
like 15 was great it was great that's
when you got the shut up mat out of him
because I was waiting for that I was
like where the where the hell was the
shut up Matt then it came
not gonna do it I
realized to do it you asked him to do it
and he said no I'm not gonna do it I
realized in that moment he'd already
decided he was gonna do it and and then
I was like no no Brad he wants you to
and do
it it was
beautiful kind of uh no yeah the
companion were great about that they
were it was such a good thing I'm hoping
we can do something again in the future
because it was it was and we got some
really good information out of Brad even
though we kept trying to stop himself oh
I've said too much but he was he was
great and um yeah we got to see a little
bit of him as well which I thought was
really Co that was and yeah he's a funny
guy he's really funny guy um I I'd love
um we have got the get Brad Wright
involved in Stargate um uh thing on
change.org the um what's it called ah
the word petition thank you Jesus I
could get out my hand my b going say
question say
questionnaire that's not right stop
saying questionnaire in my brain it's
not right um the petition I I'm I'm not
all the petition should be called it's
not right without Brad
right um I can't say more but but we
need to sign the petition we need to go
over to because um podcast guys did a
petition as well go sign that as
well okay
podcast guys I'm going to put both links
up and I'm G to get in touch those yeah
put the put the links up I'll
definitely sign both sign both
um David is a member of patreon so
patreon.com soundtrek you've got your
merch on the way excellent I'm very
happy about that sir enjoy it Go David
Ken's already signed um it's really
really important but it's
right now we've got weeks we really
really really need to get Brad wri's
name out there as much as we possibly
can right if we if we
want all it yeah he is not going to be
in charge he is not going to be the main
guy but there is a possibility of
getting him involved if we if we make
our voices heard and that is basically a
big part of what this whole video today
was on about really it was not I I
didn't want to really talk about woke as
much what I wanted to talk about was
we want positivity out there we want to
get positivity out there negativity
seems to be winning because it's more
interesting for some
reason whereas actually we should be
shouting at the top of our lungs we want
Brad Wright involved in our Stargate
because we know he'll bring something
passion to it
and but still we get comments that I
don't want Star to come back because
it'll be load and load of crap and blah
blah and I'm like no why are we getting
angry about something that's even
happened yet it's I know we live in a
very negative world but why we we could
positivity is better and then if if it's
crap then say and they'll cancel it yeah
right sometimes it's nice to just keep
it simple stupid be positive
right I'll work it into every episode
somehow some way of course you will and
we're so proud of you and so you should
sir and so you should um guys thank you
so much for for cracking
on we watched you've got four minutes go
okay so one thing he already got it
written down one thing I suggest is
lessons in
chemistry and it is Brie Larson
excellent it's um oh my wife keeps going
on about this
yes the end of the second episode it I
can't it's oh my God but the third
episode is narrated by a dog and it is
tearful the [__] dog man it that that
the dog needs an Emmy I swear um I also
watched Meg 2 so you don't have to um
because I really wasn't looking forward
to it so
okay it was just it was okay um I think
we've been seeing so many of those you
know uh dinosaur um um series you know
uh narrated aten buror and we've gotten
spoiled by the high level of CGI for
dinosaurs it it doesn't work here they
they really oh dude right it's just
right off the bat it's really a big
disappointment the story is fun you know
you know it's another Renegade
billionaire but unfortunately the
billionaire does not die at the end um
uh also another good thing was uh I
started watching this The Fall of the
House of Usher on Netflix have you guys
how is it
oh it is beyond excellent it is about
that singer user from
like about it has it it had it stars
it's Eden po based yeah it's it's it's
based on the the uh the short story um
it is sci-fi
royalty right I mean we love the
showrunner we we've got Mary McDonald
right oh
uh Carlo guino I think I'm pronouncing
her name incorrectly she's in there does
an excellent job uh Elliot from ET Henry
Thomas he's a star of the show and then
of course from Star Trek you know we we
we got oh what is his Bruce uh Greenwood
he's in it and I swear to God I was
speechless when I saw Mark Hamill as the
attorney oh cool okay oh my there too
right pardon ra Capo's in there too
right yeah yeah yeah it it is a star
studded cast the the it it starts out
like oh I know him yeah it starts out
you know
really I mean it it is a PO
worthy
um the whole childhood of Usher it is a
very po worthy scene oh my God it is
it's difficult to write one second okay
sure it's difficult to film po but they
they nail oh my God the mother oh Jesus
okay so that
um and the two books I've been reading
um the three body problem I'm going to
start that this week and been reading on
children of time which and both are
highly recommended and I think if I'm
correct three body problem is going to
come to Netflix I think am I correct
game show Runners oh really holy
[__] yeah so now I got to read all three
volumes before it comes out so I can
[__] about it properly you know and get
my hateration on I was told that the um
this will be the three body problem will
it's it's the last big budget netflixing
they're ever going to do so it's got a
big it's got a decent budget over $10
million an episode budget and it says
they won't be doing it again so enjoy it
okay basically what I was told so
they'll be looking at much less money in
future go on then Harris what you been
watching Sir quickly 30 seconds I will
speed run it but uh I've been to the
movie theaters a few times this week
because I haven't had a voice so I was
like well if I'm not talking to people I
might as well sit in a dark room and
watch something cool right but
tvwise been keeping up with Jin V it's
it's getting just better and better oh I
hate it you really it I loved it so much
that it made me want to go watch the
boys diabolical their little animated
show which I've always just thought
looked dumb and then I realized it was
just a bunch of 13 minute like episode
shorts no that's stupid second season
been we're getting it been green oh yeah
yeah I'm pumped also Rick and Morty has
come back to us and it it's it's you can
you can kind of tell in the first like
half a minute two minutes that it's not
Justin royland but after that you kind
of forget it I like the guy's new voice
uh I like the new guy the new voice guys
I guess got for it still think Sean
Kelly probably would have been better
Loki season 2 has been good I I have
been enjoying it I did not
like been some of the best well probably
the best Marvel we've seen in about five
years did you like did you like Jonathan
major at Victor timley
though I didn't mind it oh I I could I I
like Jonathan maor's an actor a whole
lot and that was just like oh God get
this guy off the screen a couple
different times yeah I didn't
mind surprised after since that Quantum
Mania after the quantum Mania post
credits I was I was worried about that
because it just feels like Jonathan
major is trying to do a bunch of
different voice cadences instead of
embodying different characters and that
is difficult but
like yeah anyway anyway besides that
1883 I finally started the yellow zone
stuff and
1883 might be even though it's just a
miniseries might be my favorite
miniseries I've ever watched it was
fantastic my my my buddy uh Jay headed
who was little kid in The Blind Side
little kid in Hancock in Blindside Tim
mcra played his dad and Tim McGraw is
one of the main guys in 80 1883 and just
was
fantastic uh besides that though movies
I saw hunting and Venice again crater
again both great check them out before
they
leave then there are two new movies out
this weekend killers of the flower moon
is one of them and it was three and a
half hours of wonderfulness it didn't
feel like three and a half hours but it
was worth sitting in that movie theater
I'll go see it again on Tuesday probably
and then there is a bilingual film right
now that is technically a French film
but it's it's French and English and it
it kind of goes back and forth uh called
anatomy of a fall France has decided
they're not putting it forward as their
International best feature and are going
kind of the route of parasite like bong
junho and North South Korea I almost say
North Korea South Korea uh that
they're trying to get it
as best picture they're putting it into
the best picture fold somebody that
hates the French other than Eric canar I
I pretend he's no yeah no I know your
question yes you would enjoy it because
FR are they going to enjoy this movie
Yes thinks that the are a bunch of
garlic stained smelly
arrogant you will be agreeing with the
main character of this movie who is
accused of killing her French husband in
France oh I like her very much the
anatomy of a fall
enjoy right hey and also Renfield you
gotta see
Renfield Harris said he hated Renfield I
really liked Renfield I loved it I
thought you know act fell apart for me
it what was one of Peter Jackson's
earlier movies Dead Alive it was just
big bloody gory scenes one after the it
was perfect
B with yes it was just awesome I mean it
was awesome in like you know in the vein
of uh Abraham Lincoln vampire
Hunter well yeah it was it was a that
and it was just wonderful and it Nick
Cage was just the only thing I could
think about after Renfield was I wanted
more Nick Cage I love Nicholas Holt but
the whole freaking like AA meeting BS I
was like I was over it in the first 30
seconds just give me more Nick Cage as a
I thought the AA meetings really made it
it was just like you know I'm
here
bit Abraham Lincoln vampire hunters and
and Reni I do do think the the final
third was a bit weak it was it started
brilliantly both films and by the end of
it was like oh we're not quite sure I
think they peaked a bit too soon but
that's really over
analy well just to correlate it with
what we were talking about earlier it's
almost like the writers were more
focused on the concept instead of the
story and wanted the little fun AA
meeting to really be like the whole meat
of everything instead of following with
what they just gave us you know instead
of following a natural storyline it's
like let's go back to the AA meeting ha
and and here we are and from and from a
effect point of view I think the the the
high point of all that was um uh
Dracula's transition from bats to smoke
and you know that was that was really
well
done I I I enjoyed it I was good I I
enjoyed Renfield but I it was a brain
off don't analyze eat popcorn and giggle
at some guy getting batted with his own
arm and I just you know just it was just
a very stupid movie but I enjoyed I
enjoyed an occasional stupid movie and
my wife sat down with um and put oh
cocaine bear is on um Sky cin and watch
it with our children so I was like
no I just thought it'd be like a silly
comedy
it's really
not there's lots of different things
going on here like six story lines yeah
loads of different loads of tone and
stuff that the tone changes from it's a
gangster movie it's a horror movie it's
a stupid screw ball comedy it's oh it's
bouns all over the place and I'm like
babe no we can't we can't um but
any
um popcorn movie popcorn power ask my
consent first
I will never shove my hand anywhere near
popcorn without asking for consent first
because I know right guys we have to go
because I'm afraid I have a thing we
gotta see what Matt watched we gota ask
Matt what he watched Matt what have you
watched mate uh I've not watched
anything excellent so he's just been
thinking about Brad rght for the last
week I have I've been watching Star Trek
I've been watching sex education I've
been watching a bit Walking Dead I've
watching loads of things but it's all
old stuff so it doesn't matter I've
still got to catch up on walking I've
still not seen all the walking I gotta
you know buckle down
and what what season are you in Matt oh
I watch Loki obviously um uh what of
Walking Dead uh season nine I think it's
getting a bit boring at the moment to be
honest so I kind of haven't watched it
for last episode I watched it for like
last Sunday or something like that
whether that counts as this week or not
I don't actually you know okay how many
questions can we think of real
quick remember just before the video
when we started when I told you a really
important thing to go and
do I got I got one thing it is it is
movie related I'll be very
quick uh yesterday like two times a year
they open the Trinity test Tite for
visitors yeah and so
uh where the Oppenheimer you know film
took place you and so I went there
yesterday it was open yesterday I got up
at 3:45 got in line at of six I was car
number
178 at 6:
a.m. and there were I think they peaked
out of like 5,000 visitors but anyway so
I went there
kidding so but anyway if you ever do get
a chance to go you should go you can
still see the U there still bits and
pieces of the green um glass sand to
glass from the blast still there it's um
so if you're a really really really
hardcore Oppenheimer uh fan uh the next
time it'll be uh you the public will
have access will be in April of next
year but it was
good
kid that's my new favorite button I'm
gonna
kid I'm gonna be using that I gotta go
have
fun we will be talking about something
less politically charged and we will
have fun one one say that
now guys have fun have a lovely weekend
say byebye everybody goodbye everybody
[Music]
toodles